[Music]
hey guys now this is another unboxing
video and this is teach and handling now
some of you guys know them something
guys do not I've tried them before and
they actually reached out to me and said
hey Daniel would you like to use some of
our products so I'm like yeah sure so
they probably hoped that I make a video
for them which is what I'm doing right
now but they did not sponsor this video
and they did not ask me to make a video
so I'm gonna be very brutally honest but
in this video I'm only going to do the
unboxing the video gonna show you guys
what their products look like and then
I'm gonna test it for a month and I'm
gonna show you the before and after
photos as well so let's dig into it
let's see how it looks like
[Music]
all right this is how the box look
playing simple teaching Hanley now
they've sent me the just we just check
here ah it says number three here so I
guess they've got these skin care levels
and this is the third level let's open
it up so when you open it up first of
all you get this guy over here thank you
for your order teaching handling and uh
okay they got some directions here like
how you have to wash and take care of
your skin will dip products in the
morning and also in the evening so all
right now first of all they say you have
to wet your face with warm water I'm not
a hundred percent happy of that because
cold water or lukewarm water would be
better than warm water for your face but
with everything else I'm happy with that
all right so let's open it up let's have
a look cool all right they've got a lot
of products in here let's check it out
so first you got this guy over here this
is the wash to daily facial wash looks
like that then you got another guy here
which is the scrub which you have to use
two times per week that's the
exfoliating scrub yes I agree with that
two times a week and then you got the a
in morning facial moisturizer SPF 20
it's pretty small this one alright then
you got the bedtime facial moisturizer
as well and then you got the super serum
am/pm facial firming serum this is
interesting and then lastly we got the
eye cream all right so that's it that's
all you get in the box there's nothing
else in here
alright this is what you get if you
order the level 3 skincare system now
what I do like about teaching handling
is that it is uncomplicated so you don't
have to use a thousand of products this
is probably maybe too much for most of
you you only need like the skincare
level one I would suggest but I do like
that it's uncomplicated it looks classy
it looks clean and the price is very
good now the only thing I don't like is
that that it is so uncomplicated that it
is not for a specific
CAIR consent for example if you have
oily skin a very dry skin it's not
specific for your skin type but I'm
gonna text it up I'm gonna take a month
text up these products and then you're
gonna see is my skin gonna look better
it's gonna look this same or is it gonna
look worse now this is how I look like
right now I've been using PC for men
sometimes to lanique and sometimes some
other products that's really really good
so we're gonna see how to Dan Handley is
gonna change my face now if you do want
to check them out in the meantime check
out the video description I've added the
direct links for you so you can check
them out you can either order it monthly
but you can also order it through Amazon
it depends on where you live and how
much the shipping costs are but I would
suggest just to hold on wait for a month
see how it affects my skin because I'm
gonna try it out 30 day so you guys can
see but if you want to do your research
check it out in a video description and
also check out those customer reviews
especially on Amazon just go and check
what people say about it you have not
subscribed yet subscribe and think that
notification belt so you won't miss that
video cheers guys
you